okay hello everybody welcome back and
I'm delighted to introduce our next
presenter dr. you and Ashley from
Stanford University before I introduce
you and just a few housekeeping notes
I'm Kevin Davis first of all the
publisher of caen en chemical and
engineering news we are delighted to be
the official media partner with lab
roots for this inaugural precision
medicine event and to have shared in
responsibility for putting this
fantastic agenda together a couple of
housekeeping notes as i said if you we
won't be able to accept any live
questions today because for scheduling
reasons we're having to pre-record this
a couple of days early we're very
grateful that he was able to squeeze us
in between frenetic grant funding
deadlines and a trip to that back home
to his native zone icing to kingdom
that's so we're grateful that were able
to snag him for a 30 or 35 minutes to
work to record this but so that will
preclude any live QA unfortunately as
far as the actual presentation goes you
can enlarge the slide window on your
screen by clicking the screen icon in
the lower right hand corner of the
window if any technical problems should
arise viewing or hearing the
presentation then please click on the
support button on the top right hand
corner of your screen or you can submit
your problem through the Q&A button
which you'll find lower left this is an
educational presentation and we're
offering free continuing education
credits so at the conclusion of you ins
presentation if you click on the CC
button which you'll find bottom
left-hand corner of the web page you'll
follow instructions there to claim your
CV credits so now it gives me a great
pleasure to welcome you and Ashley who's
recording this from the UK you and is an
associate professor of medicine genetics
and my courtesy pathology at the
Stanford University Medical Center as
you will quickly surmise you and as a
native of Scotland he studied at the
University of Glasgow I predicted his
medical Reza
seen a PhD at Oxford before moving to
Stanford University where he specializes
in cardiovascular medicine and genetics
his group is focused on precision
medicine in this field for some time in
2010 he was one of the lead authors in a
study in The Lancet on the first to
clinical interpretation of a human
genome I've very a landmark paper in the
field and he now routinely applies
genome sequencing approaches to the
diagnosis of patients in their network
he's also co-founder of personalis a
genome-scale diagnostics company UN has
give himself plenty of wiggle room with
a title of a talk that is simply towards
precision medicine so un take it away
well thanks for the introduction Kevin
and it's really a pleasure to be here
and participating in this very unique
webinar series on precision medicine
really delighted to talk to you today
and just lay out some of the exciting
new advancements that are bringing us I
think closer to a world of much more
targeted medicines for our patients here
first of all is my disclosures light and
I am find an advisor to personalis and
as you'll see on the bottom increasingly
talking to technology companies is
interesting hired this new world the
technology companies are increasingly
interested in medicine well this has
become the mean for our community over
the last year since President Obama in
January 2015 at his state of the union
said this I want the country that
eliminated polio and map the human
genome to lead a new hero of Medicine
one that delivers the right treatment at
the right time and that was his launch
of the precision medicine initiative
that he laid out in more detail at a
pressure release just a president just a
few weeks following this announcement
and it was really an exciting time it
was really a starter pistol for a race
towards a new beginning and in thinking
about how we do this and over the course
of the next step 40 minutes or so I'm
going to lay out some of our thoughts on
where we are a long bad mood of course
for President Obama this was wasn't a
new thing in fact as a senator from
Illinois back in two thousand six when
he had a little bit less gray hair than
he currently has he had a bill but
essentially laid out many of the plans
that later came to be part of the
precision medicine initiative of course
this bill didn't make it out of
committee but it shows the long-term
view that President Obama had over the
course of the last decade and his
commitment aletta making this happen and
of course a couple of papers here
Francis Collins and one and for myself
just laying laying I really what we
think about exciting time and it is
ahead and thinking about what might be
here in this new era well part of the
precision medicine initiative is the
formation of a precision medicine
initiative cohort the idea of bringing
together 1 million American
who would participate in pushing the
boundaries of science by volunteering
and sharing their own data for the
betterment of others and for the
discovery of new therapies and the
number of different themes had to be
enabled the idea of this Marian person
cord it was something that of course
President Obama had envisaged really
early on but also Francis Collins the
current directory and i h-had did many
years before talked about the benefits
of population studies and in particular
the timing is right right now for such a
cold war because of many of the things
shown here on the slide and particularly
I think we're all very familiar with the
precipitous drop in the cost of genome
sequencing but of course we're also
entering an era now a participant
empowerment and it's long delay that
should have come some time ago but it's
happy now to see that it's really
picking up their power picking up the
momentum as we start to put the power
back into the hands of the participant
subjects in research studies are no
longer we are looking for partners who
want to learn with us and really
participate by contributing their own
data and but also their time and energy
towards doing things better because
they're a major any more of that idea is
the mobile health revolution and the
idea of sensors that are embedded in
forms or in wearables that are really
again clicking the power back in the
hands of the participant and I'll tell
you a little bit about some of our own
experience and relation to that over the
course of the next little while and
finally we are starting to think about
data integration the major change that
happened over the last five or ten years
in our healthcare system the United
States it was towards electronic
healthcare records and of course there
in the most early days and are often
based on pretty old style technology but
we're beginning to think about getting
the data out of the back ends and these
electronic medical records and
integrating them with some of the more
modern approaches that are only databar
so really the time is right so what do
we mean by precision medicine and then
here's how the definition that I'll use
over the course of them the next little
while to target or prevent disease
measuring it more precisely an example
that the president used in the state of
the union with cystic fibrosis and this
has become Billy the poster child in
many ways for this approach and the idea
is to use technology and in this case
genomic technology to improve the sub
classification of a disease or condition
so that it can be targeted more
precisely when this case cystic fibrosis
really was thought of as a single
condition it's autosomal recessive
thanks probably 70,000 people worldwide
and it is caused by mutations in the
cftr gene cystic fibrosis transmembrane
conductance regulator and and mutations
in that gene that in that protein can
lead to different functional effects and
some some of those for example in the
earliest study the g551d mutation leads
to a reduction in the opening
probability of the channels and these
are shown here in the picture but of
course but in this particular setting
the channels are breaching the surface
so let's imagine that you had a drug and
I per capita is one that could increase
the opening probability of the channels
at the surface if you have a drug like
that then it would be very useful to use
it if you had a patient whose channels
were making it to the surface but
weren't opening it up however if you had
another patient for example one of the
eighty-five percent who have they have a
delta 5 weight lesion then those
channels are often disrupted destroyed
because of Miss folding and don't make
it to the surface and in that case it
doesn't matter how good your drug is at
improving the opening probability of
channels on the surface it isn't going
to be helpful for those patients and
this is really the essence of precision
medicine that by understanding the
disease better at a molecular level we
can target it better with appropriate
treatments and in fact another drug that
improves trafficking for those class two
patients luma captor has now been
approved and even this combination
strategy is possible for the delta final
week patients whose challenge reach the
surface they sometimes have a gating
abnormality that can also be held by
either count them so this really
describes a new world another one for
area this precision oncology and really
cancer has become redefined as a genetic
disease it has for many years we've
appreciated that this somatic changes
can predisposed to cancer and we started
to define cancer biology in a very
different way we do have fda-approved
drugs for a egfr from albury arrangement
and lung adenocarcinoma about we find
this when i'm targeting rose often
targeting the driver mutations that we
find that quite open further somatic
here mutations led to therapeutic escape
and so they release this therapies were
not as successful as we formed in the
new era of precision oncology I think we
find many many areas where genomics can
help with diagnosis and therapy we can
think about John wine risk first of all
of my DNA sequencing we think about
identifying driver mutations but we can
also think about neo antigens we know
that yours are nihilist for the immune
system and that there are challenges
with checkpoint deceptions and they
ought to inhibitory effect on T cells
but we can sequence T cells or we can
sequence the t cell repertoire in the
new year we can use our own a season
thing and to identify a checkpoint reset
from like and gene expression in the
tumor so our understanding of biology of
cancer has changed greatly and when we
think about it vaccination is a strategy
in cancer and the combination of that
sort of strategy with the power of
genomics we really striving a new year
one of great excitement for the future
of patients with these conditions well
from the future I'm going to take your
local back into the past because it
wasn't so long ago that said genomes
really cost a huge amount of money more
than we could ever have thought of
spending in our patients back in two
thousand name one of my colleagues deep
quake had sequence his genome with just
a couple of people in its loud for forty
thousand dollars which while that seems
like a lot today but at the time it was
our temple production from the genome
prior to that and occurred to us at that
point that perhaps it we should start
thinking about what would happen if
patients were much more routinely going
to walk into their doctor's office
with their genome if you like on a stick
order settling on a hard drive and so
that led us to start to think about it
what sort of algorithms would you need
what sort of tools will you need how
much computing power and the manual
power would you need to analyze the
genome and so we put together a team
back then my group was focused on
Mendelian disease and we started to
think of a genome-wide destruction the
open reading frame starting to think
about how do we build some tools to do
that this was by this was a helical
genome so even an earlier time before
alumina genomes were the standard
approach we also knew that
pharmacogenomics was going to be
important and my colleague knows Auburn
has been running for many years with
Tara climbed upon gkb too and so we had
database that was already very well
curated and available to tell us about
the effect of genomic variants on drugs
and finally we were increasingly
improving the gos catalog and my
colleague attribute had put together a
database for common variants and their
effect on disease and we thought that
combining these different approaches and
tools with the lowest perhaps to start
to provide a personalized approach to
medication treatment and to diagnosis of
disease and thinking about future risk
and we work that up over the course of
the last larger part of that 2009 one of
the stories that came out when the paper
was polished was was this one around
trying to get personalized
recommendation for statin therapy as the
quake himself was a 40 year old man at
some risk for coronary artery disease
from his family history but the
guidelines shown in Venice more current
here were really no help because when
you plunk Steve into these day lines is
said at the end physician choice was the
best thing so that wasn't very helpful
and so we wondered if his genome could
be more helpful what we found were but
were really in since genome but we'd
suggest he had indeed inherited the
family history and that he was able to
tell us about the more common variants
that pushed hard to tell how much but
that pushed a little bit in the
direction of positive risk of disease
but I think much more importantly we
were able to find he had variants that
showed that he would likely respond to
the drug and even one further
that he also had that an absence of the
variant that would suggest he would
likely have a side of a and so we were
for the first time able to get me
personalized recommendation really from
a person's whole genome sequence towards
their medical care and this was that Lee
inspiring to us but it took many many
months and people a lot of manual labor
and the course of the last few years
we've tried to work on with reducing
that amount of time and also thinking
about improving our algorithms well one
of the groups have contacted us shortly
after we published that paper was his
family John West and his family he had
become famous as the CEO of celexa who
managed the sale of his core business to
alumina and had been one of the first
that families ever chibi sequence on
they were going to platform and so he
wondered it we could help him the same
way we had done was teaching on to
interpret his family's you know I'm
et/pt breath away the head with that it
was obviously exciting to have a whole
family and to be able to think about it
dating analyses like the one you see
here and Houghton state analysis across
found the quartet and thinking about
exactly which parts of the genome were
inherited the two which child from from
which parent and of course that is
important because we can start to work
out once again which part of the family
history is most relevant than did the
individual kids inherit the actual risk
for disease and in joins Casey was
particularly focused on his fiscal pawan
embolism or clotting because he had
suffered a bomb remember wanted taking
warfarin has a good patient should but
then suffered another one and so he had
been particularly curious to work out if
there was anything in his genome what
would help them give his children advice
and how to avoid a similar thinning and
we were able to provide some help with
that make some recommendations on that
basis and the power of then having a
whole family of genomes was obvious to
us as well as thinking about the benefit
in having parents when you're trying to
work out what for example is de novo
because many of our conditions are we
think of congenital heart diseases one
in that category but many cases we see a
child is affected with parents who are
unaffected and our line goes to
heterozygosity organovo models of
inheritance when we see that and so this
was one of the first times I think we
were able to think to what sort of our
movements will need to be in place to
think about inheritance across a family
when we think about the clinical part of
their genomic analysis we also were able
to produce error by using the family
information to reduce the the archer
brother genero in the range of which we
could define crossovers below on kb for
the first time and phasing is important
I mentioned two component hitches that
girls will think well being able to do
chromosome when facing phasing is
something and that is possible using the
computational framework showing here and
but is otherwise challenging as we move
towards longer reads of course we were
much more commonly be able to face and
genomes and but that tech world is just
coming up well I mentioned the reduction
in cost and sequencing and that
certainly being transformative a change
from a human genome project funded at
three billion dollars down to your
thousand-dollar genome has been quite
spectacular but of course the cost is
only one thing and there are some
situations in medicine where you really
want it to be vast as well as cheap and
one of those situations is the intensive
care unit and in particular the neonatal
intensive care unit and so I wanted to
tell you this story about one of our
patients who came into the natal
intensive care unit at Stanford
Children's Hospital and this little baby
suffered from long QT syndrome so may I
take just a moment to explain what that
is for you an ECG is shown here on the
left the gentleman with the number pad
stuck to his chest it's an electrical
tracing of the heart and you end up
seeing waves that are for historical
reasons labeled p q r s and T and that
is the depolarization of the heart or by
the repolarization of the heart so the
recovery each beat and the distance
between the Q and the T wave as known as
a QT interval and if you have an
inherited condition of the heart muscle
called long QT syndrome then that
distance is long and you are predisposed
to dangerous rhythms and that's what
this little baby suffered in fact she
will
brought in at 36 weeks of gestation and
delivered by caesarean section and the
first day of her life she suffered by
cardiac arrests so very dramatic
presentation in fact she became one of
the youngest babies ever to have unempl
anted the percolator you can see it on
the right of the screen there in her
abdomen with the league tunnel birth to
work so hard and as I mentioned the long
QT interval itself is not so much the
problem as the predisposition to very
dangerous rhythms like the one shown on
the bottom left of the screen which is
tor sad upon which is turning around the
points a very dangerous heart rhythm
with a heart essentially pumps a new
blood and so this little baby suffered
five cardiac arrests in the first day
but one QT syndrome is redefined in the
new year in the precision medicine era
as a genetic disease and one where we
have specific therapies that work better
for specific subtypes of the disease and
in this case if we had a way of knowing
which some type this little girl was
suffering wrong we could personalize the
therapy but the current test costs five
thousand dollars it sequences five genes
and it usually takes about six weeks to
come back so we decided that wasn't good
enough when we wind up for a new route
we spoke to her friends at the woman who
agreed to sense do this rapid turnaround
genome sequencing over the course of a
weekend we drew the one on a Friday and
by Monday afternoon my postdoc James
priest had worked through the genome
through one of the rapid coach
algorithms to find as Casey any two
million there was a known cause of long
QT and because we're able to work out
there's a lot of way we were suffering
from the form or long QT syndrome caused
by a potassium channel gene rather than
a sodium channel gene we were able to
personalize the therapy of this little
baby and I'm happy to tell you that over
the course of several months she has
done very well went the hospital she
still has a defibrillator in her abdomen
that this is a picture of her here and
she still continues to do very well to
the steam so I think that's a nice
example of precision medicine in
and the idea that the transformative
potential of genomic technology and
being available not just cheap but fast
it is really quite significant not a
part of this labeling theme of the
precision medicine cohort is the idea of
participant in Parliament and the idea
that patients are no longer waiting for
the doctor to tell them what should
happen or to read the doctor to go find
the next breakthrough but i rather doing
that themselves and so this is a story
from that night of hunting down his
son's killer this is an actual blog post
that he wrote I find my son's killer it
took three years but we did it not quite
like this I should clarify one point my
son is very much alive yet my wife
Christina and I have been fine
responsible for his there my son
Bertrand has a new genetic disorder so
the story that took Matt to the point of
writing this blog post was that his son
had an undiagnosed disease it was
affecting his neuro neurological
development and he had managed to have
access to an early excellent program at
G and some variants had been fun but the
challenge is that if you have a disease
that no one has suffered from before and
I'm hearing it is found in a gene that
has never been associated with the
condition before then it's very
challenging to prove causality and Matt
had been well known for her Walbert had
talked about surviving his ph.d and so
he went to the Internet to try to track
them other patients that might have
similar symptoms including some rare
symptoms like a lack of tears and he
wrote this particular blog post that
became viral and was ricocheted around
the world and it led in fact to the
finding of several other individuals
with the condition and the narrowing
down of the calls it was featured in
this new yorker story here's barking and
Ron is bad and if I'd to this paper in
the end describing that mutations in n
goeie one and this new condition of my
one cousin inherited disorder of the
inconstant particular suit integrity
shun pathway and go I can AIDS being the
enzyme
they pathology being consistent with
this reduction in the degradation and
his particular molecules but the most
important thing about the story is
really what happened next because this
was an important landmark but really am
at another parents like and my position
here your patients at Stanford really
started to get together to work together
to find other families to connect and to
start to raise money so that they could
fund researchers to try to find a cure
and this really describes a new world a
brand new approach where the
participants of the patients and the
families and they're really pushing the
research forward as hard hard as anyone
else and I think new technology is what
facilitates that the idea that you can
go on the internet and you can write a
blog post and you can connect with other
individuals and I think our community is
catching up we're now thinking about
ideas like matchmaker exchange
connecting individuals physicians and
scientists across the world who might
have patients with similar symptoms or
you might have found the gene that you
believe might be causal but you need to
find that second piece and this is
really describing a new world in fact
the new world was illustrated as much as
anything by the fact that in this
particular editorial was written by the
appearance themselves these approaches
are one of the many inspirations for the
undiagnosed diseases Network the
undiagnosed diseases program has been
very successful one has been formed at
the NIH and medical program over the
course of the last few years but was
expanded just in the last two years to a
network around the country I know you
can go to a centralized gateway and
apply and again it's the patient who
applies
if you're a patient with an undiagnosed
disease you can gather your records
together get a letter from your position
and apply directly to the Gateway where
your case will be tries to one of the
different sites you will review it and
you can have a relationship with that
site as you visit truly an opportunity
to apply the best of technology whether
it's genome sequencing whether it's
multi or me excuse me coming Yung
diagnose disease network is an
opportunity to apply the very best that
medicine has to offer to these very
hardest of cases whether its genome
sequencing whether it's for make
assessment of the immune system with the
network tries to comport where that has
in the past or VPN stagnation going even
beyond the teen on then we can think of
ways of which technology can really
facilitate precision medicine and a
particular you might be familiar with
this which is the back of another watch
this particular one it's gold-plated and
seventeen thirty dollars and so it's
quite possible that is not the one on
your wrist right now but it's certainly
a new world where we are able to have
kind pieces that are able to shine LED
lights into our skin tell us a better
physiology talking of that here's one
from Samsung this one is not
commercially available but as multiple
channels of LED light it's also possible
that it can take an ECG that I described
earlier an electrical tracing of your
heart by placing your right palm on your
black dress we have been testing these
devices in our good because we're very
interested in the potential impact on
patient care but as with genomic
approaches were very interested in high
accuracy if you need to know that these
devices operate a clinical grade with
where we can start to use them and so
we've been testing the wall on the lab
here's the initial test from a Samsung
device as compared with polar heart rate
monitor that goes around the chest and
use some data from
that we done looking at sitting walking
running and cycling in the lab there's
also a field-based component to this
particular test where we send people out
your own Stanford campus cycling and
having their cardio metabolic parameters
measured by this rather attractive blue
mask that you can see and shown in the
picture because you have two arms and
you can fit two watches on each wrist we
are testing multiple devices at once and
you can see some of the earliest data
from our casting you what we found is
really that the heart rate monitors of
the latest generation are significantly
improved on the generation before and
are under many circumstances quite
reliable not surprisingly perhaps
cycling is a little bit more reliable
for a watch based sensor because your
wrist is like a lot more stationary on a
bite then it is while running or even
walking but these are certainly
significantly better than they were at
the current level I think we would
caution who would advise caution and
over interpreting the caloric estimates
because they seem to be continually as
still very noisy but the heart rate
monitoring is significantly better than
previous we've got particularly
interested in this because we had the
opportunity to work along with apple and
several other academic centers in
launching the research kit platform on
iOS and we were focused on
cardiovascular health and we worked
along with the American Heart
Association this was the study that we
put together which uses surveys based
through the phone and physical activity
monitoring and fitness fans threw for me
was launched at the Apple spring forward
event in March of last year one of the
really i think transformative things
about mobile health and about the
opportunity to build research kitchens
that we were able to get IRB approved
consent informed consent on a mobile
device for the first thing and really i
think we were very proud of this as much
as anything else that we did to the
ability to offer patients and
participants information that was in a
handy format on their phone each cream
looks like this is an opportunity with a
simple sentence to learn
or on each screen but a key number of
screens take you through and take you
towards the end and we're at the very
end of after signing a consent form you
get presented with this and this I think
is even more transformative because not
only are you in charge in the sense that
you're doing your own consent in your
own time on the bullying you then are
able to say exactly which data points
you want to be part of a study and if
you get up to Warren decide that you
don't want your date of birth to be in
the study anymore and you can pull like
reform pull up the screen and slide the
slider back across I think the ability
to put the power in the hands of the
participant it is really transformative
and something you are very proud to be
part of in pushing forward its new gira
also something I think we'd be excited
to see a very much as product of the
precision medicine cohort still another
thing will be excited to see there is
the ability to use security features
that are built into the port for example
touch ID this has been developed and
keeps all your personal information
perhaps your banking information and
other information on your own secure so
it should also keep the data you have
chosen to share with a study secure and
so we were happy to be able to build
that in also we can use wearables here's
my wrist and my Apple watch reminding me
to complete the my heart kind survey by
the way if you're interested in this
particular study you can download it
free from the App Store and join we
currently are in the final stages of the
first seven days of collection we asked
if we participant to give us seven days
of data and then we leave you alone for
a few months and but the second version
of the study is just coming where we
start to randomize among different
coaching approaches to improving and
increasing your physical activity well
when apple announces something the world
pays attention and we went from really
literally nobody in the study to 10,000
people in the first week to 30,000
people in the person 1 and 2 over 50,000
people now in the study and just a few
months later this was really an
unbelievable change when you consider
the amount of effort that would have
been required to collect this much data
on 50,000 people previously for example
70s and physically
tivity how do we do that currently we
asked people what did you do last won t
have any flights of stairs at your
client last Tuesday do you remember I
can barely remember what I had for
breakfast this morning never mind what I
did last Tuesday so having a bone in
your problem or a wearable that is
monitoring not just your activity but
for example your heart rate is really a
new world from the point of view of
doing these kinds of studies having it
available and could do those people it's
quite significant this was from our
first data freeze physical activity on
18,000 people just checking to make sure
that we have sanity here this is out of
the day along the x-axis and proportion
of individuals active or inactive shown
in green and as you can see it has the
correct pattern people get off of the
warning they exercise a little bit more
at lunch time a little bit more at the
end of the day of course we're really no
more than twenty percent of the
population are activating one time and
so we have quite a bit of work to do
because we knew the physical activity is
among the most potent drugs that we have
and that it helps the physical activity
helps the help of every single system in
our body we can also use some of the
approaches to high-throughput data that
have been pioneered machine learning
approaches for example here just came in
fostering of the patterns of activity
instead of us defining the patterns of
activity we let our participants to find
them by their own activity and so rather
than us deciding that one group is it in
one area and one group is in another we
can see what people actually do in lipa
data and speak to that and although this
is an observational study of course
there's no causality here we've already
seen associations between physical
activity clusters and the presence or
absence of disease we can do fitness
tests as well this is how we would
currently do a six-minute walk with this
test at the hospital will be a nurse in
a clipboard and some are walking along
the line so we do know I'd side with an
iphone in your hand and walking and and
keep turning around if you need to but
certainly in your own time on
when it's convenient for you if you look
you want it to look at the past and see
for the six-minute walk because what
would be normal you might link to the
literature and you'd find these kinds of
studies a largest study being nine
hundred participants and if you think of
running nine and participants three or
six min at work that is a long time if
we take in the first few weeks of our
study we had 5,000 people complete when
I have a kind of six minute and one of
the joys of being able to do this is
that we can return the result back to
the individuals in this case we ensure
the cool part variation for the
six-minute walk distance and sure where
you as an individual fall as particular
incentive to continue to be physically
active come to work and if you need it
anymore incentive then the statistic
from our paper that was published as a
couple years ago it should be enough we
often think we don't have time to
exercise but the data for exercise and
physical activity improving your life
you're doing is really beyond repute and
in particular one minute of exercise
buys you five minutes of extra pipe so
you really do not have an excuse not as
signatures as talks finish to go out and
exercise a little bit more well and
finally for the last few minutes I
wanted to talk to you about data
integration we talked about different
data streams that are coming from high
technology precision medicine here we
talked about genomic data between on its
size we've talked about we will later on
its size talk much for electronic
medical record data but we've mentioned
that in the you Leah increasingly we get
information about our patients and
information for participants in studies
coming from that way what we are
interested in is whether we can combine
this data and certainly one of the
ambitions of the precision is in court
study is to be able to combine that sort
of
perhaps also a social media data so we
can learn more by participant behavior
the point of view of a position we would
love to be able to integrate this data
in real time at the bedside or in the
outpatient clinic so that it's available
for us to make decisions for our
patients and so we've been working along
with the essay p innovation while period
Stanford in developing a canyon next
generation medical record something
where we could combine into the wig
theta with wearable data an electronic
medical record data and this is shown
right here this is from a bio archive
study that just posted last week and
here in this situation we have 38
patients in a an example clinic all of
whom have had their own genome sequence
and you can pick on one individual as we
did there and look through and what that
system will do is look into their
electronic medical record and do natural
language parsing to essentially pull out
ontology zor provide particular events
that would be associated with diagnosis
and you would see one here and read
showing the number one the top of the
screen we have a timeline series of
analysis of the medical record but at
that point where there's one in red the
diagnosis was made in this case it was
cardiomyopathy a disease of the heart
muscle so that trigger to look up for
the PCF file for the genome for this
patient for any genes that might be
associated with Carter minority and you
can see that they're showing at the on
screen just underneath other things we
can do for every patient of course [ __ ]
blood type the MHC and thing about HLA
typing as well as ancestry the amazing
thing really about a system though is is
it runs in real time so as the screen
refreshes the natural language parking
is carried out on the data file and the
genome data is looped up at war time and
brought into the prior screen in front
of the position but we also have
wearable later and this is really just a
pilot study but of course view have
heart rate and accelerometer for your
patience you can tell what they're
exercising so that's good and there's a
point in the middle of the screen there
where the heart rate children blue and
the energy in yellow are both high and
that would suggest the patient's
exercising a little further along where
you see the red bar
you can see the heart rate is high but
yet the yellows children the energy
level is low this is a point where the
heart rate is high but the patient isn't
moving so that would suggest the time of
stress and so we can use the wearables
now to point out these things and bring
that to the attention of the position
and bring it to the attention of the
participant or the patient so that they
can alter their lifestyle in a way that
would lead to a reduction of their risk
well we're not quite at this point yet
you can't list your iPhone as your
primary care physician well some of my
patients would like to do that they
think and maybe they'll prepare a right
or as a cardiologist as well but we're
not quite there yet but we're moving
certainly in that direction and I think
this new world of precision medicine is
an exciting one to be moving towards I
present to work from a lot of different
people weezer a few of the folks at for
my lab and the groups who fund of the
work over the last few years that I've
shared with you today you know the the
team from the my heart codes app if
you're interested in downloading it and
joining the study please do we should
have an android version also coming out
soon baby I'll finish with a quick plug
for our conference big data and
biomedicine if you want more of this
kind of information and some of these
speakers that you see shown on screen
come join us and suddenly Stanford
campus and me and we'd be happy to
welcome you when we can talk more about
big data in biomedicine but future that
i think is bright I think precision
medicine is really transformative idea
it's one for which the time is right for
which win when we have a genomic
information really at their fingertips
when electronic medical record data is
coming and increasingly we can look to
wearable technology to tell us what some
work give us a much deeper picture about
the physiology of our pain in patients
thank you for joining me today and I'll
be happy to take a couple of questions
so in terms of those questions I have a
couple here the first question is this
Ted you're involved in the first in
depth clinical interpretation of an
individual genome in two thousand
and hers that process improved in the
past five or six years and what do you
consider the remaining chief problem
areas well I think that's a very good
question because I think that we've made
a lot of progress in the last few years
but that we're not there yet at that
time I think we had a group of maybe 25
people working for six months in one
genome and so we've definitely moved
further ahead than that we have much
improved our those many parts of that
process that were quite mantle of the
tenement no longer manual but the final
mile the final part is still very much
manual because it means we were
individually new or when one variant
someone could be evidence for their
causality and many cases we still cannot
do better than looking at the raw data
in a GV of the screen I think one by one
we're getting better but there are still
many areas where improvements in the
algorithms could really take us forward
for example we're pretty good a single
nucleotide variation a recent study that
we published just a year or two in JAMA
showed that if you compare two different
platforms for full genome sequencing
then most of the time a high ninety-nine
percent of the time those two platforms
would agree but that figure dropped to
around fifty six percent and when we
thought about insertions and deletions
and if you think about the propensity
for insertions and deletions small in
dells to disrupt the open reading frame
when therefore potentially cause disease
then that's concerning and if you think
also then the structural variants where
we disrupt a reading framing more where
we're equally poor at looking at those
and I think there is still quite some
way to go before we have everything a
clinical grade we also want to think
about coverage if you can see an area of
the genome you can't call it and you
need to be able to see enough bases at
high enough quality to know what the
valency like colbert's so I think we
have some way to go I think we've done a
lot we've made a lot of discoveries
using the algorithms developed for
improving predominantly for Court the
discovery but to take this up to
clinical grade will require a little bit
more attention
and I think there was one more question
mentioning that I'm a competitive person
else which is a genome-scale diagnostics
company and the question is first person
i was making impacted precision minutes
well again I think this is a company
that was founded with the idea that we
have to bring genome sequencing up to
clinical grade and the idea of accuracy
at it's very cool and the company has
focused a lot of Mendelian disease up to
this point and in thinking about the
point I was just making about coverage
and the capture approaches that we use
for exome sequencing I have large holes
and sometimes even whole exons that are
missing and so the idea of of
maintaining that coverage and making
sure that we really can make a call at
every coding base position it's really
important on one that person is focused
on I think the idea of being able to
replace current technology is based
around the idea of non inferiority you
have to the very least be in
non-inferior to current technology and
if we think about what we use clinically
we do Sanger sequencing and we use my
curly technology to look for structure
we envision so one of the interesting
approaches personalis has been taking is
to the so-called thin whole genome so
along with an Augmented exon there can
be little coverage of the whole genome
this maximizes cost-effectiveness but
also a lot of structural variant calling
really in one single test that's a very
exciting new area I think that person
alice is following and i think the final
one is that the ecology is precision or
colonies is an ADA I mentioned at the
beginning and one that I think many are
very excited by the idea that we can
have near-term therapeutics that will be
personalized for the through vaccination
and other approaches and so that's been
another area of focus for personnel
okay so thank you and somebody then
thank you for joining me